[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's delicious I just love eating dinner
as a family oh please you haven't eaten
with us in weeks plus the pot roast is
cold because we had to wait 15 minutes
for you to come downstairs for dinner
here we go Abby can you uh pass the salt
please
whoa what was that all about I asked you
to pass the salt not the attitude Oh
like you don't know what this is about
that's rich come on dad well come on
what is this about what is this about I
found these in your dressing room
who the hell is Rebecca she's nobody I
can explain are you seeing another
sidekick
another sidekick wait a minute no yeah
that's crazy you do have another
sidekick you son of a [ __ ]
I'm not a sidekick we're just having sex
you're not helping
through this two are always fighting get
back here
we are eating dinner as a family no
we're going to where our real family is
Hometown Buffet we stopped being a
family a long time ago don't worry about
them they'll be back when they need
money good one boss didn't even thought
Rebecca shut up oh it's all ruined
I miss the dinners we used to have I
miss us Andy don't you see this is
and this is coming move this spring
untidiness
thanks for standing up by the way I
appreciate it
one guy stood up okay
you